Oh my god, this is just like.
My kink is Karma. Chapel Road.
We broke up on a Tuesday. Jay kicked me out with the rampage.
Ruined it,
stole my cute aesthetic.
I really feel like these people are, like,
dead inside. They don't have the human capacity to feel like,
we know they have no empathy,
but then they also do not have the human capacity to understand, like,
oh, that's cute and pretty.
That's weird. That's,
you know, they like,
they literally don't know how to make up their own style,
their own identity. So they either completely, like,
adopt your personality,
steal your cute aesthetic,
like, do what you do,
cause that's like the only, like,
human thing they know how to do.
Or they just find somebody else to replace you who's like
an exact clone of you, like the Walmart version of you.
Do you know what I mean?
So that they don't even have to change their own thinking or aesthetic.
They can just bring in a new girl that's just like you.
She's a Latina. She is.
Has curly hair, she's a Sagittarius and has golden retrievers, and
they're just.
It's weird. It's super duper weird.
And that's why it's so important to, like,
leave them,
cause you just don't wanna pick up their ugly habits and shit.
And you do, and it takes a while to unlearn them, so.
Oh, I love the girlies that got it.